would-be asylum seekers who tried to
cross the border into the european union
are reportedly facing illegal and
violent pushbacks
new investigations using video
recordings and documents show an alleged
campaign orchestrated by special police
units in croatia greece and romania to
forcibly keep migrants out
at croatia's border with
bosnia-herzegovina investigative
journalists found systematic use of
force by special police units funded by
the european union now as
a member of the european union croatia
is required to allow any migrant
entering there to apply for asylum in
the eu
allegations of so-called pushbacks have
been circulating for years journalists
filmed this incident earlier this year
the footage shows masked men in uniform
and armed with batons beating would-be
asylum seekers apparently to stop them
from entering the european union
one of the masked men could be heard
shouting go to bosnia
the group of asylum seekers were from
pakistan and afghanistan
medics from doctors without borders
later treated their injuries and said
that they were consistent with being
being struck with batons
the masked men did not wear badges but
they used equipment that active and
former officers say is the same as
croatia's
border police
well my next guest tonight is a
journalist with lighthouse reports which
has been at the forefront of
investigating what it calls the shadow
armies on the eu's borders klaus van
dyken is an award-winning war
correspondent who filmed that striking
video that we've just seen colossus good
to have you
on the program before we start i just
want to share with our viewers what you
tweeted today
you posted hiding in the trees listening
to the damp thwack of batons on human
bodies the screams will be hard to
forget as has been the case with
reporting from conflict zones it becomes
more troubling with distance and
reflection
there's a powerful words there class
talk us through what you saw on the
border
it started um i think with um
entering the the area
where these pushbacks are are happening
um and we know we knew or we found out
where where the exact spots were
and um
we
we had to crawl through through the
forest basically um
and hide there and wait um and then at
some point we we heard a car coming uh
from from the other side of a river
um and
the the slamming doors um and that was
on the croatian side so we were on the
boston inside hiding um in in in the
forest
um and then the first thing that i heard
were with the beatings
and i think we were
well less than 30 meters away um but
still it's it's quite a distance but
then when you hear the beatings and the
screamings and that are coming out of
the
uh from the other side of the river and
yeah that's that's um quite shocking um
and then we saw people jumping in to the
river and they were forced into the
river by by these guys wearing dark
uniforms and balaclavas on their faces
and clouds how did you know where
to wait and when to wait
uh where is that we we work with a with
a team of journalists um of from all
over over europe um and there have been
people building up a network um along
the border uh with just local contacts
who helped out to to tell because a lot
of people know where where these things
are happening
um and um they were they were able to
give us directions um and to to point us
to to the places where we had to wait
and then it was also uh just just luck
um so sometimes something happens and
then other other times
um yeah we had to wait for days and
sometimes nights and nothing happened
the european union's executive has
voiced serious concern over the pushback
reports and has called for
investigations in greece and croatia
here's the eu's home affairs
commissioner speaking earlier today take
a listen
i must say that the croatian government
takes this very seriously they were
going to immediately investigate the
minister was shocked and i think they
are doing exactly the right thing
my discussion with the greek minister
was different and i have made clear that
i will not accept that greece do not
do the investigations on this we have to
protect our external borders but we also
have to protect our values the rule of
law and fundamental rights
so what do you make of what you just
heard there you know she said that the
minister was shocked do you buy that
and not for a second um they know
exactly what what is going on and also
uh people in the european union or the
european uh the eu commissioners they
they also know that this this is going
on and they knew it for for a long time
already there have been reports um from
from uh from journalists ngos activists
um
and but this is the first time that
there is visual evidence of it so they
could not longer deny it
and yeah that's that's why this material
is is important that it's out there
um
to so tonight croatia
said that they suspended three officers
that apparently were seen in the video
um although we we
saw four video four men in in the video
but they found three of them and they
did it within within half a day um so on
all the other reports that are there on
all the other violations they it's it's
very easy apparently for them to just
find the officers and investigate
okay but this is the first time to
actually do it
klaus van dyken journalist with
lighthouse reports klaus we appreciate
your reporting we'll be following this
story we know you will be come back and
talk with us when there are new
developments thank you
thank you so much
you